pourquoi le port d'une abaya pour les
filles ou d'un camistre pour les garçons
est une atteinte à la laïcité
extrêmement claire l'école le collège le
lycée c'est un sanctuaire c'est-à-dire
qu'on ne doit pas deviner la confession
de du jeune c'est un lieu qui est
protégé de tout prosélytisme religieux
politique ou idéologique et quand on
porte en réalité une tenue un signe
religieux classique une croix un voile
ou une qui passe c'est évident on sait
que c'est un signe religieux on est tous
d'accord donc c'est interdit il n'y a
plus de tentative en tant que tel pour
aller tester l'institution scolaire et
donc la laïcité par contre quand on
porte une tenue qui n'est pas au premier
abord et un signe religieux une Bahia ou
un camiste survêtement mais que en
réalité c'est un signe religieux par
destination dire que c'est la vocation à
montrer une appartement tout à fait et
bien notre la réponse du ministre
papendaye mais qui est également le
fruit du vademe comme de la laïcité qui
a été portée par le Conseil des Sages de
la laïcité et très clair fermeté c'est à
dire non quand un habit est
et par destination un signe religieux
alors il est interdit et il n'a rien à
faire au sein de l'établissement
scolaire en fait ce phénomène est porté
par les réseaux sociaux oui et
d'ailleurs pas peine Yaye on parle dans
son interview aujourd'hui à au monde où
il dit qu'il faut que la République est
plus forte que TikTok c'est la
République plus fort que Tik Tok une
forte que Tik Tok mais c'est pas limité
seulement aux réseaux sociaux il y a des
phénomènes de groupe des phénomènes
d'influence entre élèves aussi qui font
que c'est phénomènes émergent et il y a
une tentative de tester l'institution on
voit jusqu'à où l'institution peut
résister derrière cela alors c'est
toujours difficile il faut le prendre au
cas par cas déterminer mais sur les
réseaux sociaux vous avez comme la dit
papénia et des influenceurs islamistes
des proches de l'islam politique qui
pousse et qui impose auprès de la
jeunesse un vocabulaire de contestation
permanent de la laïcité qui essaie de
faire passer la laïcité pour une
interdiction stigmatisation là où à
l'inverse la laïcité c'est un outil de
liberté qui permet à chacun quand il on
se retrouve à l'école d'être libre de
penser par soi-même et de ne plus
dépendre du de des opinions
confessionnelles politiques ou
philosophiques de ses parents Benjamin
Duhamel Jean-Michel Blanquer c'était son
sujet la laïcité la même parfois traité
de laïkard pas
une priorité on n'en faisait pas une
priorité il a été obligé de se saisir ce
dossier oui on voit bien qu'il y a une
très nette correction dans le discours
par rapport à ce qui était celui du
ministre de l'éducation nationale au
mois de juin juillet ou en somme la
doctrine consistait à dire il faut qu'on
regarde précisément il faut faire
attention avec au fond l'idée que dans
ces sujets plus on en parle plus on
accélère le phénomène de personnes
allant tester le tester l'institution ce
qui est un comment dire pour le coup une
inversion totale par rapport à ce qui
était la ligne de Jean-Michel Blanquer
qui lui en faisait un combat extrêmement
ferme d'où ce besoin de s'en saisir mais
là où vous avez raison c'est que ce
n'est pas comment dire le cœur du
discours de papy n'est pas un discours
en faveur d'un discours extrêmement
offensif sur la laïcité d'ailleurs même
on voit bien dans l'interview du monde
il y a une drôle d'expression il parle
de laïcité positive il insiste beaucoup
sur la liberté là où Jean-Michel
Blanquer lui était dans une épure plus
proche notamment des compas des combats
autour du printemps républicain ce qui
est inquiétant dans ce qu'on voit là
c'est qu'il y a une de la part des
personnes qui testent l'institution et
de la part de ces influenceurs
islamistes une perversion de la notion
de liberté c'est à dire que les
personnes qui portent une abaya qui a
mis un bandana ne n'y vont pas en disant
je veux affirmer mon signe communautaire
mon appartenance à tel ou telle religion
elles disent mais au fond je suis libre
et au fond pourquoi est-ce qu'on aurait
le droit de mettre un crop top de mettre
une mini-jupe et qu'on aurait pas le
droit de mettre une abaya ou un camis or
c'est une négation absolue de ce qu'est
la laïcité et surtout une relativisation
absolument incroyable et c'est vrai que
ce point de vue là il a peut-être manqué
je sais pas bien une forme de combat
culturel qui existait chez Jean-Michel
Blanquer cette question j'ai envie de
vous la poser en quoi c'est gênant une
jeune fille vienne à l'école en albaya
est-ce que ça ça gêne ça scolarité
ça pose la question de ça dépression et
donc c'est un signe religieux par
destination aussi déportés de manière
régulière
ça n'a rien à faire ni au collège ni au
lycée mais le combat
ça gêne le sanctuaire quelle école libre
la laïcité c'est un principe absolument
essentiel c'est même une valeur dans
notre pays mais pour faire le point
entre Guy et Jean-Michel Blanquer ce qui
est certain c'est que les deux défendent
pleinement et fermement la loi de 2004
qui dit il n'y a pas de signes religieux
dans nos établissements et oui la
continuité
on ne pouvait pas imaginer que le camis
la Baya le bandana et peut-être sûrement
demain faut pas oublier que c'est une
offensive idéologique d'un islam
politique et pourquoi il y a une
augmentation là en ce moment c'est
offensive elle est le fruit aussi d'une
idéologie qui est conquérante et qui
essaye de tester nos institutions et
l'institution première c'est l'école
républicaine et pour poser juste un
point et un sujet si aujourd'hui on est
en capacité de poser un diagnostic c'est
parce qu'on a formé plus de 1200
qui doivent protéger l'enseignant si
besoin mais il faut pas frémir si un
endroit qui doit rester solide et dont
les digues le fait doivent naviguer
sceller évidemment l'école justement
ceux qui sont souvent en difficulté
c'est les enseignants mais aussi les
chefs d'établissement parce que la
difficulté qu'ils ont eu souvent face à
ces tenues traditionnelles nouvelles
c'est de savoir est-ce que c'est une
marque culturelle ou est-ce que c'est
une marque religieuse et donc ils
attendaient depuis longtemps des
instructions précises du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale qui leur disent
qu'est-ce qu'on fait il y a eu une
circulaire une lettre le 16 septembre
qui disait notamment s'il y a un refus
systématique doté s'est tenues ou si
c'est tous les jours à ce moment-là ça
devient signe religieux mais le Conseil
des Sages de la laïcité avaient
travaillé sur cette question depuis
début juin c'est à dire que Pape Ndiaye
a attendu pour qu'on fasse passer les
consignes entre début juin et le 16
septembre donc c'est vrai que ce qui est
là que je rejoins ce qui a été dit tout
à l'heure disons que Papen Diagne on
peut pas dire qu'il en parle pas de ce
sujet il en parle il dénonce encore ce
matin l'islamisme etc mais c'est moins
son cœur de sujet et il met plus de du
temps à s'exprimer sur cette question
avec qui je travaille tous les jours moi
ce que je vois c'est que non il n'y a
pas d'autre je vois au contraire un
combattant de l'école de la République
Jean-Michel Blanquer mais on peut pas
comparer les deux c'est chacun sa
personnalité chacun ses méthodes par
contre ce que je vois c'est que la ligne
du gouvernement est très claire c'est la
loi de changer elle n'a pas changé
maintenant ce qui est certain c'est que
moi le ministre que j'ai au quotidien au
sein de l'éducation nationale c'est
aussi le ministre qui protège cette
école qui protège ses enseignants et qui
va dans la continuité de ces travaux et
si la réforme si la lettre arrive en
septembre il est arrivé juste avant à la
fin de l'été mais pour moi le plus
important c'est de s'appuyer sur
l'intelligence du conseil des sages et
de leur expertise sur les conseils
jamais ce conseil des sages pas
pengaille si vous regardez l'interview
au monde par exemple il y a aucune
référence pour ton conseil
des professeurs qui est quand même un
outil hyper essentiel pour faire en
sorte que les chefs d'établissement les
professeurs les assistants d'éducation
soit tous au clair sur cette question il
y a 130 000 professeurs qui ont été
formés c'est un tour de force depuis le
printemps sur un million de personnes
mais 300000 l'année prochaine mais c'est
énorme c'est beaucoup vraiment
les questions les plantes formation donc
pourquoi il ne le met pas en valeur et
puis c'est vrai que mon confert le
disait il y a vraiment eu un retard à
l'allumage une rentrée ça nécessite des
mises au point dès le départ les chefs
d'établissement qui dès le départ ont
mis au cœur de leur rentrée de leur
réunion de rentrée avec leur professeur
la question des abayas n'ont plus de
problèmes d'abaya ça se met ça
s'organise en amont de la rentrée ce
retard là il fait sans doute aussi ce
que il explique aussi sans doute
je l'entends et en même temps moi je je
souhaite pas qu'on laisse imaginer qu'un
le transfert de responsabilité de charge
ceux qui mène cette offensive au sein de
nos écoles ce sont les milliers de
vidéos aussi sur Tik Tok et d'ailleurs
il faut qu'on voit TikTok bientôt et
c'est dans les tuyaux parce que c'est
comment on enlève ça ce sont des mineurs
sur Tik Tok celles qui font de ces
vidéos là elles appellent à déroger et à
des actes par des adultes et si c'est
vrai que derrière tout ça très
sincèrement il y a des milliers de
vidéos ça n'est pas spontané moi je ne
crois pas que ce soit spontané par
contre est-ce qu'on a des éléments de
preuve et bien il faut qu'on ait les
échanges avec la plateforme qui les
diffusent il y a des milliers de vidéos
ce sont des mineurs entre 13 et 17 ans
ce n'est pas anodin et l'idée de ces
vidéos c'est de déroger à la loi de 2004
c'est à dire la loi et de faire des
infractions à la laïcité c'est quand
même le sujet principal et comment lutte
contre ça avec la reconquête et un
combat offensif pour une laïcité pleine
et entière dans notre pays et aussi
reconquérir le cœur des jeunes sur cette
laïcité aujourd'hui il y a un sujet il
s'approprie pas ce magnifique principe
qui est un essentiel
soit la question générationnelle
aujourd'hui c'est certain il n'y a pas
de il n'y a pas la même
la même lecture de la laïcité chez les
plus jeunes et les plus anciens
et puis il y a bien sûr puisque c'est
interdit je défie l'interdit ce qui est
un réflexe aussi adolescent peut-être
chez ces jeunes un phénomène de
contre-culture mais de volonté de tester
l'institution même si si on se limite à
cette analyse on ne voit pas la
spécificité qu'il y a autour d'une forme
de de volonté de dentrisme islamiste
mais là où c'est intéressant vous avez
raison c'est qu'il y a un sujet
générationnel dans tous les sondages où
l'on pose la question au 18-25 ans de la
façon dont il perçoivent laïcité de la
façon dont il perçoivent le possible le
lien qu'il peut y avoir entre la laïcité
les discriminations dans la façon dont
il perçoit une forme de perversion de
cette notion même de liberté il y a un
combat et à mener et de la même manière
même culturellement quand on a pu voir
ça peut paraître anecdotique mais la
façon dont Diam's récemment au moment de
son film apparaissait comme étant voilée
comment dire parlant de sa du fait que
elle ne pouvait plus faire de musique et
la façon dont tout ça a été accueilli
dans une forme de silence embarrassé
général alors que alors même que c'est
une personne qui est une sorte d'idole
de de la jeunesse cela pose question sur
la façon dont les politiques sont à même
d'expliquer que la laïcité est un
facteur d'émancipation auprès des jeunes
et auprès de ceux-là même que ça
concerne et que ça va continuer à
conserver au moment où les Iraniennes
arrachent leurs voiles en Iran et c'est
un combat et je pense qu'il est
absolument essentiel que dans notre pays
à nous il n'est pas d'indignation de
poids de mesure enfin permettez-moi
juste cette parenthèse parce que on ne
peut pas soutenir ces femmes iranien et
dire que c'est une avancée et qu'il faut
les accompagner et que dans notre pays
et bien ne pas protéger ce principe
absolument essentiel à notre cohésion
nationale et donc le défendre est
reconquérir et bien le cœur des jeunes
et l'esprit et bien de certains jeunes
parce que oui c'est un essentiel merci à
tous